if you want extreme happiness as a
purebred entrepreneur it's all about
employees mmm and incentivizing the [ __ ]
out of them because you're an artist and
as an artist you want to write your song
we need to understand that entrepreneurs
are artists you what Pablo Picasso
didn't want to Co paint you got your
perspective what's up guys back to biz
on the bore norm a podcast I am [ __ ]
fired up cuz I've got a guest on the
show today that honestly is [ __ ]
blowing up my world uh Gary Vaynerchuk
thank you folks [ __ ] being on the show
thanks bro typically the way the show
goes is I try I pose the question
whether or not you think you got to
where you are today because you were
born with an innate ability to do it or
you were built over time or mail all the
time let's save a lot of time in this
show forever in perpetuity the answer is
both it's proven that it's both like
obviously some people skew one way or
the other
but we are like like they figured out
this nature nurture thing forever ago we
all keep layering on top of it oh wait
can I just say so so you say both yes
but you also say that there are a [ __ ]
ton of fake entrepreneurs so like if
it's both you mean you have to be born
with it and then you build it over time
nope
I think in that example where you're
going with that is entrepreneurship
school now mm-hmm
just like in 1978 being a rock star was
cool and that's why every [ __ ] dude
wanted to have a band how many of them
became the Rolling Stones not a lot
that's what we're living through right
now mm-hmm
everybody wants to be an entrepreneur
right now for the first time ever you
know not ever but definitely in
contemporary pop culture and 98% of them
will not be successful entrepreneurs
well why do you think because I know my
answers to this question and I don't
typically ask the guest until the very
end and I very rarely say what I think
but I am 100% convinced that you are
born
this way is but you but the drive that
you got from the way your dad rolled
since I've had you on my podcast or the
fact that I couldn't speak English
because I wasn't born in America then I
immigrated here is a massive [ __ ]
variable I think adversity definitely
plays a huge role in let's stop right
there if you and I were the grandkids of
each other instead of each other
fool T everything else we're gonna be
different
bro you and I have real chips on our
shoulder this is where I want all these
[ __ ] to get losing and [ __ ] is
phenomenal
oh yeah bro that's exactly you and me
yeah growing up in Greenwich third
generation wealthy we're you and I are
different
I'm telling you I've got another
question here you know the level of
disrespect you and I consciously and
subconsciously have for a third
generation wealthy Greenwich it's bad we
don't think they can beat us it's bad
well it's a bad good look just let's go
to raw let's go to like winning in Reno
what does it please but but I actually
don't even think it think like I just I
I it's interesting I don't think about
that though I don't it's not like I
think about like when somebody comes to
the table and I'm trying to do something
with somebody I'm like actually in the
middle of it right now I'm working on a
project I got a new project that I'm
working on and there's a dude that I'm
working with what [ __ ] love but he
can't get out of his own way and there's
a reason why and the reason why is
because pop douche blesses his life like
it's just it's just bits bro if you
don't think that you and I with all our
[ __ ] talent if pops Dukes blessed our
life would be different I know you know
that to be true yeah I get it I get it
but the question is there so for
everybody that's [ __ ] listening I
don't think you've ever been asked this
question okay if you are that dude or
that girl yes right that has been
blessed and you're [ __ ] 25 I've taken
the more 30
stop picking top taking the money I know
you're gonna say that but is there a way
is it is it too late or cash you got
that [ __ ] that's what can you reverse
the totally different great question
that is a totally different question
than the first one mm-hmm is it too late
no no it definitely is not I actually
believe no it is not too late do I
believe that you're 25 think about how
devastated by the way it could be a
hundred percent wrong but I'm about to
deliver a sentence that is not fun to
deliver because I do know that 26 year
old Sara and Rick are running right now
on a treadmill listening to this they
fully know that a third generation been
taken care of they know actively right
now that mom and dad pay for uber they
know actively right now that the doorman
building in Manhattan is paid for by mom
and dad they know everything and now
they're saying [ __ ] this is a
vulnerability they believe us they
decide to cut off dollars they do want
to change they want to be on their own
two feet and merit-based here's the
problem yes you can fix it I think you
start really getting results at 31 32 33
if you're 41 right now I think you start
really getting results at 57 58 but
don't you think this is it's like hi I
put in the excerpt I just want to finish
the thought you're gonna have to put in
the work it's like extra if you've been
eating like [ __ ] and not going to the
gym for 38 and a half years like I did
mmm did it take four [ __ ] good seven
days a week eating and working out to
finally form into something at least
decent yes it did for a hundred percent
and if I started 22 I'd be [ __ ] I'd
look like you I'm being dead serious
it's not super complicated
no that's and I always bring it back to
that me but but what I would say is is
this if you are 25 26 30 [ __ ] 240 and
you've been living off the [ __ ] the
the Tina - the the cheat money tree yeah
I think the hardest part of that is
actually starting cuz you don't get
where you got without going through the
[ __ ] [ __ ] right like unless like from
where we came from bro you know what's
harder than what we did coming from the
dirt is going into the dirt when you
lived in the past and I'm saying so that
that's gotta be so I thought where is it
reversible I don't know it's reversible
if you become aware that it's your
vulnerability the reason I've had some
incredible interactions in the last
couple years I've had people call me cry
let
oh my god I have subconsciously resented
myself and my parents I'm 33 years old
I'd never heard anybody say cut them off
first you [ __ ] on my parents for
entitling me and I was like yeah and
then in that same podcast you later said
oh by the way you know I've been
[ __ ] on your parents now [ __ ] you
stop taking the money I'd never been in
a place of accountability I kept saying
my parents [ __ ] me up the Upper West
Side [ __ ] me up
Harvard [ __ ] me up goldman sachs
[ __ ] me up my friends [ __ ] me up
I never was accountable and saying I
could stop taking the money mm-hmm like
like where are we right this is gonna
air fairly soon cool instead of having
your parents pay for you to go to st.
Barts this New Year's you could say no
just say no but do you have the humility
so do you think the what you're saying
is stop taking the money full stop if
you want to [ __ ] put some [ __ ] on the
map and you don't actually feel good
about yourself because you're lying
about you know smiling in my Camry or
[ __ ] crying in my Ferrari I think is
as real as it gets
it's the realest thing I know I think
it's people that don't have wealth or
like Carrie that's [ __ ] only rich
people talk about money not having
happiness so like now it's perspectives
I saw so so another question
you know entrepreneur yeah what the [ __ ]
does that mean for me the way I've
always thought about it is this cool
game where you live on your own two feet
it's completely merit-based it's the
closest thing to sports and you get to
do what the [ __ ] you want to do however
if you suck you die you die in that game
you have to go get a job is what I mean
by that so it's the most merit-based
which is why I think it's fake
entrepreneurship now because you might
even grow up with this concept of
raising capital but how do you know if
you're a [ __ ] entrepreneur not like I
know how I knew because I was [ __ ]
onto [ __ ]
from as early as I can remember listen
if you sold [ __ ] without knowing why the
[ __ ] you were selling it before the age
of 12 it's in the mix okay so if you if
so you have polarized this whole thing
if you know if you don't [ __ ] listen
to this guy you're [ __ ] hiding under
a rock that you shouldn't be hiding
under because you've polarized this [ __ ]
in the realest way if you are fake
entrepreneur and you [ __ ] know it
because nothing [ __ ] works you have
zero creativity in your [ __ ] life
what do you do well first and let's talk
about it because listen because you're
so cool which is fun so I'm gonna assume
so many cool people listen to this look
I'm so empathetic listening right now
I've never heard of me
so let me take a step back all this
energy you're feeling right now
this is not [ __ ] ritalin this is not
[ __ ] redbull this is deep gratitude
and passion to help that I'm so grateful
I'm almost feel guilty of how much
happiness I have because of
circumstances of parenting and
entrepreneurship and immigration and bad
school and all this stuff
look I'm empathetic to the kid that we
just punched in the gut who knows that
he has or she has on tremendous it's
this excuse a little bit more mail but
it goes both ways
has entrepreneur in there Instagram
account because that's like a good thing
to say at Eugene's spot and 2:00 in the
morning like it's really cool mm-hmm you
know what do I say it's gonna lead you
down depression in the same way that
your parents forced you to be lawyers
and doctors and engineers and all those
immigrant kids are deeply depressed at
42 the reverse is about to happen all
these kids that are using their bio and
saying they're an entrepreneur but deep
down know they can't do it mm-hmm they
need to get off that [ __ ] drug they
have to self-aware wait okay so but well
nothing I want to say one thing
self-awareness and humility and
accountability are the greatest paths to
happiness and nobody wants to do that
can I tell you what I think the greatest
path to happiness
straight up please fitness and [ __ ]
wellness I'll be obvious it's great out
of everything in my life so I just I
just sold a bunch of equity in a company
okay and took one of the larger checks
I've ever taken in my life which is
always a fun moment it's a fun moment
guess what this was the most polar I
just happened last week I was sitting in
my [ __ ] car and I just you know I had
just done this thing and it's in your
account you like Eddie in Miami but you
know the funny part when you see it
nothing changed changed I believe I mean
nothing I mean nothing from like I buy a
[ __ ] train like I didn't buy anything
nothing you know why you're in a good
space let me let me say this what would
have happened 17 years ago of that
check-in yeah it'd be probably a
different story let's talk about that
the reason nothing changed is you're in
a [ __ ] incredible spot right now but
can I tell you why I'm an incredible
spot because I wake up at five o'clock
every morning I'm in the gym at 5:15
your process and that's it you find your
process like it's not about [ __ ] for
you ready for a furnace
you know why I'm an incredible spot
because I wake up every morning making
pretend that my parents or children died
no listen everybody has their thing
some people are an incredible spot
because they work out some people
because of the type of food they now eat
other people because of a mentor listen
one of the things that I'm so grateful
for in my life some people in a great
spot because I [ __ ] penetrated their
dome over the last four years because
they've consumed 80,000 [ __ ] hours of
my [ __ ] and I did it for them just like
my mom did it for me just like some
people did it for you the dude that
[ __ ] helped you when you were [ __ ]
grown you know like I love that [ __ ] let
me just give you something new so by the
way is this [ __ ] birthday not
tomorrow
it's true and on your show yes we talked
about doing something and we didn't do
it until now oh my god I'm so pumped I'm
gonna wear this tomorrow
is this a medium don't don't I need a
medium of course yes you're the best I
love my [ __ ] parents but yep I
remember that moment I gotta go look
back at it I don't think we clipped it
we didn't clip it we need to clip it
Jason that would remind remind me cuz I
remember was a huge moment what was the
part I make it you you would ask me a
question and it was something about my
parents and I was like you know I love
my [ __ ] parents but cuz I'd moved out
of my parents house and then you were
like what was it and I was like I love
my [ __ ] parents but and you were like
that's my t-shirt yeah yeah so like
everybody says that and my big thing on
that is take the butt out and whatever
the [ __ ] they did alcoholics beat you I
mean like there's some extreme [ __ ] and
then you got people who hate their
parents on some lightweight [ __ ] the
mostly emails I get are one of the two
extremes Gary you don't get it though
like [ __ ] heinous [ __ ] that I'm I don't
actually not I'm gonna repeat it here
like I'm so uncomfortable like real
gnarly shin or entitlement like it's
funny to me the person
that says I hate my parents I love my
parents but they paid for everything and
now I resent them at 27 because I've
realized I am a zoo animal hmm for them
that's as real as the person that had an
alcoholic parent that punched him in the
face
because you both are affected it's your
reality who do we get to judge which
one's better or worse as if FFT if you
look at suicide rates a lot more of the
[ __ ] zoo animal than the one that got
punched in the face it's crazy
yeah I mean I think that so I think that
everybody would everybody I apologize
because I'm passion about this everybody
wants to make their thing the worst
mm-hmm
you don't get it I'm an immigrant you
don't get it I'm an African American you
don't get it I have a dad who had was
bipolar you don't get it I had cancer
when I was four I just want to tell
everybody needs more compassion
everybody's got [ __ ] mm-hmm
everybody's trying to prove which
person's suppression or [ __ ] story is
worse and my whole thing is let's go
reverse let's just acknowledge nobody's
got it great and everybody's potentially
got it great the one question that I get
asked all the time consistently over and
over again how do you get fit how do you
work out how do you manage how do you
balance life and [ __ ] mobility I
think that there's a very simple answer
that is really common sense that is so
[ __ ] crazy that people that people
actually have the audacity a word that
you've been saying a lot to ask if you
want something there's only one way in
my opinion there's only one way to get
it and you gotta [ __ ] do it period
can't that's it can't read about push
upset [ __ ] that's it bro you preach it
that's it but I think everybody who just
heard that and this is where my
conversation on this issue has evolved
this is why I got into judgment you know
why so many people that weigh 413 pounds
don't go to the gym who can't afford a
private trainer they're worried about
the judgement on day one mm-hmm well I
think I mean I think you're right I
think that that's why [ __ ] at-home
Fitness has taken off right a hundred
percent but then at at Hope but you know
how many people can't be accountable to
just in themselves and actually need the
gym environment
so what is
that is okay let's talk about that
person oh my gosh so there's this
question I [ __ ] have good and this is
a question that I think is so [ __ ]
important totally unrealistic let's just
put yourself in an unrealistic bubble
for a moment I think high school is
[ __ ] [ __ ]
I just do I think high school is
[ __ ] good I have not applied a
single thing that I [ __ ] learned in
high school to anything I do today
outside of networking and socializing
that's that that is the one thing that I
think high school so if you were given
an opportunity to change the curriculum
for today's [ __ ] human being in the
high school and high schools across the
country what would you do I would flip
the model of one curriculum for all to
individual curriculums to everyone at
scale you and I would have loved high
school if all of our classes were
entrepreneurship networking maybe hey no
no look at this
listen I got a bag of tricks here want
one other thing so I was looking for
[ __ ] because I thought it would be fun
to have some [ __ ] on set with you and I
found this in my high school diploma you
found it and in my high school diploma
you want to know what I found report
card my final report Calexico cuz you
know how proud I am of my [ __ ] look just
looking
where's is if you got a class rank as
bad as mine I just did forty three out
of two little people lookit look at my
class my class it at my absence is holy
[ __ ] dude so it goes Esav Lea economics
29 yeah but like economics sucked in the
school way I didn't I should show up to
this class I just I just never went like
this was so much so but what made me
think about this question why I wanted
to ask this tea was how can i what would
change you know what's awesome everyone
pay attention this they break it up into
three sections the audacity that our man
Michael rolled with in in section one
the beginning of the year for absence
six lates
now let's build on that section two five
absence only one more seventeen links so
what you see an entrepreneur here
because he's a
he's understanding how much he can do
third nine absence so he matched the
first two and twenty five lates did more
than the first two combined obviously
it's a little warmer a lot of the more I
understand that you were pretty boy I
know what you were doing so so high but
but like what this said to me was like
you know there is an opportunity like
there if I get I go hard and extreme on
[ __ ] I love like if there's something I
love I am the most real straight
somebody and again back to this by
fourth grade we 5th grade we know that
Sally is type a wants to be a lawyer
wants to do this and let's give her a
curriculum if we find little Garrity and
little Michael let's get them into
something far more creative and
entrepreneurial let's just hunt a little
bit I mean I really want to pull it you
know I want this this was I was like you
know what I want to [ __ ] hunt with
Gary for a moment and if there's a
possibility it's not you know it's not
no grip no grip ease so Juan Gonzalez
this was this was on olerude Gonzalez
I got a Mookie Wilson big shout out to
Mookie leer Mookie Wilson was my guy and
it's also weird as a bluejay not a met
that your urine your a Jets and Yankee
fan which is a weird [ __ ] combo it's
a weird combo but not for some it's a
weird combo because Queens is [ __ ]
mess but as you know I pulled a [ __ ]
Juan Gonzalez did you I literally call
him the best card and [ __ ] pull did
you I pulled a Juan Gonzalez [ __ ]
rockin Paul's the best bang literally
said this was the one and got it first
pack let our second game my god thank
you here's why I was born in Russia so
because I was born in Russia I didn't
have my grandfather who grew up in
Queens telling me on Mets and Jets not
only was I born in Russia so I have to
start my dad didn't know American sports
I'm the first I'm the patriarch and of
my family's fandom and I grew up in
Jersey
which is very split so I she was very
split so that's how it happened
I've got by the way it sucked cuz I'm an
80s baby the Mets were much better than
the Yankees and let me say he's a
funniest [ __ ] singer of all time so
my father was
born in Queens I'm the fourth-generation
New York City I am the first non Queens
kid how we doing on time we got time I'm
actually taking a photo while you were
talking by the way everyone's like how
do you make content I'm like you just
make it like like I'm literally taking a
photo of this one Gonzales card you're
gonna I'm gonna push it on Twitter while
you're talking make so 1986 the Mets won
the series my father never met Sam it
missed a Mets game ever ever ever we
could be anywhere and he had a little
[ __ ] radio with him he never missed
the Mets games amazing 1987 Mets were in
the playoffs and Darryl Strawberry 7 or
88 did they make the 87 playoffs Damien
is against the Dodgers when Scioscia
hits the home run no it was a strong I
mean anyway it was any exam and maybe it
wasn't a plan service in 87 strawberry
charged the mound ok I don't remember
what game it was I was towards the end
of the season strawberry charged amount
- strawberry was my god he was Mike it
was my god
of course and he charged the mound and
and he's a [ __ ] fast [ __ ] and
I let him over he got he like actually
charged him out and actually like laid
some [ __ ] punches in there
and I looked at my dad and I said dad
why did Darryl Strawberry just beat that
guy up and I very clearly remember my
father looking over and being like son -
strawberries a full-on drug addict and
that was it I became a Yankee fan
overnight why I dropped everything I was
like a drug addict and that was when
like Derek yeah that was like when [ __ ]
dude I'm coming bro I'd never listen to
me
I'm the byproduct of Nancy Reagan I've
never done a single drug in my life
because the propaganda during that time
was so intense Owens and my mom made
that religion and I was a good mama's
boy and like I didn't I you I used
entrepreneurship for escapism
I didn't go there and like to this day
at 1:44 I turned 44 tomorrow have never
I mean sugar and coffee but like
anything could I've never smoked a
cigarette
I've never about you I obviously but by
the way that's a fun one if my dad
didn't have a liquor store I'm convinced
I mean I didn't have a beer until I was
21 years old I was crazy straight-laced
on complete so in high school very
shortly I'm
straitlaced I was scared shitless of sex
cuz of Magic Johnson I was completely
convinced that if I had sex one time
that I would have eight Wow yep
I was super not fun or cool in that my
personality you know it was awesome like
in like my personality traits I was
addicted to the [ __ ] game of
entrepreneurship I was a character a
class clown popular from like my
kindness like I crossed over Jean Rezai
like did a lot of good things but I was
not cool because I was absolutely not a
drug or sex kit and that is the
requirement of cool in high school yeah
that is the you know that is the cost of
enter I mean I got I got when I came
into high school I was young I was 13
and by second semester high school 13
years old I turned just turned 14 I was
a complete animal you know like a
[ __ ] changed overnight for me yeah
and then by the end of my [ __ ]
freshman year I was selling drugs to my
whole entire high school yeah and it was
[ __ ] nuts all right I want to
quickfire some because I wrote these
questions out and I think that it's
important to get him so if the Jets were
winning consistently like had won a
couple of Super Bowls in the last five
years ten years would you still be on
the path do you think I I believe that
you would not be on the path I believe
that you really but I would not be on
the path you would not be on I believe
if the Jets win a Super Bowl before I
buy them there's a chance that you're
gonna want to buy the next yes yes I
believe that to be true Wow I dropped
the Yankees and Rangers listen I'm gonna
post this cuz I gotta find I gotta go I
think I'm gonna my parents this weekend
actually my yearbook in high school has
more references to the New York Rangers
than the Jets mm-hmm yeah I think you
got the scoop
I knew it I'm about the hunt yeah dude
when I was doing this when I was scared
of sex in high school my great moments
we're just getting the girl to like me
it was the chase 100% but I think that's
classic I think that I think on a large
scale like what I say to [ __ ] myself
and everybody else like if you don't
learn to love the heart and the hurt
your [ __ ] hundreds like if you don't
actually love it like actually you know
yeah I love the process you have to love
them for me it's about learning to love
the heart of the herd like people like
you know I just went through this not
awesome situation with my with a
business and it was like oh I'm sorry
and I'm like sorry it's [ __ ] awesome
I like I love it I like sorry I'm right
I'm [ __ ] you know what I would have
been great at UFC was because everybody
loses I would have been a great UFC
fighter I would have loved being this
kid 24 and 8 you know and like be at the
bar and be like yo remember when I
knocked out Tito but remember when
[ __ ] Shane choked me the [ __ ] out
like it's merit mm-hmm yeah all right
let's keep going um so I thought that
that I think that that's pretty
interesting
your biggest burn in business can you
talk about that well look I mean I'm 44
years old tomorrow and I built one
massive business for my dad and left
with $0 mmm and I built another massive
massive business and then buying out my
brother you must have some situations
that just like [ __ ] left a really bad
taste in your mouth talking about like
business like failing in a business I'm
talking about just like burn partnership
anything I'm going right to it the
family business is the best and hardest
part everything else is kind of easy
like I lose money all the time like I
start divisions and new concepts and
I've written I mean I wrote a check into
somebody's startup for 250 and this is
all my own money
mm-hmm you know what your two inch
$50,000 is to me I made 40,000 50,000
60,000 or every year in my 20s this is
like enormous amount of money to me
still and like the company failed within
the first year like like like unlimited
I hire people that fail all the time
like here's the one thing that people
don't understand about being good at
something like I'm never gonna make a
business
that puts me into death mm-hmm so
everything's a micro cut there's a very
big difference between breaking your arm
and dying in a car accident mm-hmm
so when people like what are your
failures I'm like you mean breaking arms
but they want some sort of story where
like you like I will never save too much
money [ __ ] it so we'll move on to the
next one but by the way real quick just
to add to everybody everyday okay we got
fired today from a big client for some
[ __ ] today gonna lose 1.3 million in
revenue that I now have to make up for
next year I pay bills yeah you know like
everybody every [ __ ] day so for me in
business whether I'm the CEO of the
company or not my number one hurdle is
my CFO just number one hurdle so for
marketers guys like you and I brand guys
culture guys community guys long game
guys what is how do you how do you
approach your CFO with a [ __ ] with a
conviction and compassion conviction and
compassion conviction and compassion
that's right and and I'm compassionate
for you CFO that you've found yourself
in the back urea spot that you're in one
of those 5% places where you're not
actually the boss and let me say that
nice and slow for everybody listening
because most people on the other side of
this don't know this truth most
companies are actually run by the CFO
not the CEO on a person I don't have a
board I'm not held to publicly traded
company dynamics I have 100% control
thus this is one of those rare places
where my CFO has to conform to not
having power on the flip side I have
compassion his whole career has been
under a place where he's had that
don't-don't-don't die so I want him to
like get reconciled even though we're
near three now with this CFO but but I
would like for place so most people
don't have that
that [ __ ] ability right so like if
there is a team within a company that
feels so passionate about something yes
and the CFO is like no we're simply not
spending the [ __ ] money on that howdy
and they don't have the control to
necessarily say well actually we are
spending the money
how do you propose an idea to a CFO
thank you
you just don't you do not because a CFO
she or he is a certain animal you're not
gonna convince a tiger to start flying
it is that binary mm-hmm you can by the
way you know me people listen to be like
he's wrong and then I'm gonna answer to
everybody on the other side of this
podcast you're right I'm sure you can
point to a time where after four and a
half months to years of conversation
finally you were able to get something
done do you know much time you wasted on
the other 99% of times that you tried to
get something done that could not get
done 100% because they would not waver
it's [ __ ] up man
I I think it's not [ __ ] up well it's
actually kind of like Republicans and
Democrats which is like look everything
is the best when it's in the middle
culturally right now in our politics
were in the reason everyone's feeling
tension is we're pulling away from each
other
mm-hmm same in business CEO CFO right
especially co-founder visionary hmm
she's always gonna be on the offense
it's the CFO use themselves as the
person that keeps her in line let me and
editor editor and a good CFO actually
comes from a good place they're like wow
she's so dynamic I'm gonna be back here
making sure nothing gets too crazy so
that she can see her vision through
right I believe that there's a lot of
great CFO's so yeah that's when a CEO
and CFO work great they've got vision
and compassion for the CFO CFO feels
like he's empowering or she's empowering
her vision but that still doesn't mean
that four times a year they get to a
crossroads where the CEO she thinks this
is the one idea that's gonna take us to
the moon and the CFO goes [ __ ] this is
the idea that can [ __ ] us inelia
friction right so that so I think the
question that comes typically is talk to
me about ROI on this [ __ ] and in this
initiative this is why goes back to who
actually has the leverage I don't have
that conversation right I'll appease it
out of respect right just like that but
I think that it's it's it's really sad
because I feel like the way we got it no
it's what what's sad is is that like let
me tell you why it's not something
you'll push you this the reality is this
is why parenting is so hard it's
actually a place where
the nature of having a child leads to
two cooks in the kitchen but in reality
I'm sure if everybody takes a step back
right now one of the parents is still
the one a parent decision-maker mm-hmm
well guess what that's how businesses
are you the one I in your house I am NOT
I am NOT a tit
uh-huh but I'm the one a in my business
yeah and that's it like there is no coat
there's no partnership decisions are
only made when somebody makes a decision
I also at lease so it's interesting
because I was Butler real quick it's a
partnership but still somebody has to
make a decision yeah yeah no I agree
yeah but but in business partnership you
know classically people are taught that
you should find a partner that
complements your skill set right so like
your grated [ __ ] in marketing and this
person is great at [ __ ] financials
right like because because the marketing
guy is typically not necessarily
thinking about the [ __ ] piano and i
you know i think i don't think it's i
think i agree with you i don't think
it's partnering with somebody like that
I think it's hiring hiring for a hundred
percent that's the one that going
forward that is that's it that's it for
me that's it I'm 38 like you say I've
got another [ __ ] 80 years to go right
I've we're [ __ ] doing this is why
we're gonna be unstoppable
no really I think the fact that our
generation is having these thoughtful
conversations like bro I swear to God on
everything
the Jets my kids you know society I
think the biggest business I built
probably get started in my 60s I'm just
gonna be so unstoppable experience I'm
like I haven't even started I can't I
agree I can't believe how good I was at
25 listen five years in I take a
business from three to 60 million with
no money like I was an all-star I'm an
I'm the LeBron Kobe type like like like
I'm very comfortable saying out loud
right now like look yes like I'm gonna
be in the mix like people are gonna
conversate about me in 50 years as a
real [ __ ] player yet that 26 year old
that had all that talent is a schlemiel
compared to the guy sitting here right
now experienced [ __ ] an imagine 30
years oh all right I got a few more of
these questions that I think are
important
is there a these are sort of more
restaurant focus let's go
happy hour yes I think it's a it's a
brand that feels old hmm and just
changing the terminology and a single
tweak about it could start a whole
revolution suggestion if you're 5 to 6
p.m. or whatever hours you're trying to
drive egg
give it a completely different name and
incentivize it in a way that isn't just
predicate on better pricing so so
potentially service some something about
the service create something called 72
minutes and it's this whole thing called
72 minutes and it starts at 5 p.m. and
ends at 6:12 and and then now that we've
created the container in my ideation and
brainstorming with you here right now
now we say ok besides good pricing what
can we do from an experience from a
programming from some left-field other
third idea that really drives people
running out of their [ __ ] office to
be in this 72 minutes I like 72 minutes
on digital marketing and restaurant
space outside of traditional marketing
like old-school [ __ ] TV commercials
that nobody in the restaurant business
at my level has any can even [ __ ]
begin and would never want to do today
anyway outside of the Superbowl like you
said content at scale content at skill
so like talk to me about that like so
let's talk about a trendy place because
you come from that kind of world like
really being hip and smart about it
not just how good the scene looks that
is the one-dimensional move that
everybody makes look how cool it is here
also so that's your first Instagram post
but your second one is a two minute
nineteen second Instagram TV of somebody
making the shrimp cocktail and we get to
know that Juan is here like who is one
back there here but I'd like I'd like to
straight up oh yeah I do that so like
but and I know a lot of [ __ ] people
that do that my question is it's not
EECOM so like there's no click through
in the restaurant world right like
outside of making a reservation which
[ __ ] 90%
gets canceled what can restaurants like
somebody's coming up brand-new wants to
launch a restaurant young entrepreneur
actually [ __ ] hustler like gets it
understands the digital space what
should they do to get butts in seats in
restaurants either back to listen you
just said to me you play basketball and
I'm saying be LeBron I know that you
[ __ ] post on Instagram I'm talking
about every [ __ ] nuance underneath
that mmm look I don't want to leave I'm
gonna give you another one for your
answer but let me say it very clearly
this is what I spent a lot of time
looking at you can absolutely drive your
business if you have a proper tik-tok
twitter facebook youtube podcast
linkedin strategy and you put me out
under piece of content at scale against
imporant demographics what restaurant in
America right now is casting African
American actors to be in the content of
how good the nightlife looks there and
then running it against ads against only
African Americans within a one-mile
radius let me save you time goose
[ __ ] egg so before we go over I do
that others do that first do the thing
no no no real quick but it's important
it's gonna help people listening first
that number two and this is it either do
the thing that's current completely best
or break the rules let me give you an
example I've been thinking about
starting a restaurant called
subscription which is exactly what it is
you have to pay a subscription fee with
a heavy cancellation fee that derives
guaranteed revenue for me so I can staff
against it and you decide if you're
gonna will you just come and eat for you
you pay a monthly fee and then you just
come here whatever you want everything's
everything's [ __ ] there's no playing
with names like I called it subscription
24 which means you get to go there twice
a month like it's a good luck thank you
people have been doing in the coffee
space so there's like it's a melancholic
look this is and by the way between 72
and subscription 24 in this podcast
you've just uncovered an insight that
only I in the last year or two have
realized about myself because of my team
which is I have never given credit to my
own self on how creative I am within
business and that's why I innovated in
hindsight it makes sense but like think
about the two things I just by the way I
just I da ting them like ice
say I've been thinking about that those
are passing thoughts there's never been
a time that I've put two words
subscription 24 I just know that
breaking the framework is how you win
that game like if I here's what I'm good
at
if I ain't hurt let me finish this talk
cause it's gonna really want to get it
out if I said what I always do if I saw
on Twitter or if you or eighth honor
eugene or Noah texted me and said hey
have you heard about subscription 24 I
would be like I would do what you need
because you're smart
[ __ ] that's smart that's how I try to
come up with ideas mm-hmm by the way
people love [ __ ] new [ __ ] do you know
many people love I mean like something's
gonna go and execute this idea right now
that's listening which makes me happy
yeah but you know what the [ __ ] don't
worry about that idea is you're [ __ ]
it you're out of sealing right like you
like you I mean is there a subscriptions
weren't there so so there's a
subscription can they spend more money
when they're there like is there is
there like is there tears for it how
about this you're not an what if it's so
perfect that you just have 8,000
locations globally like there's never a
way to like you can also change the
pricing you can put in a word like that
we will always give our subscription
price a 12-month preview to a new
pricing structure to your point we can
ID eight and say the food's locked
alcohol isn't that's where all the
upside is anyway I think you know like
you could go in perpetuity on this for
four minutes or four minutes and to
brainstorming this idea partnerships I
think of the hardest [ __ ] thing on
the planet
like the hardest [ __ ] thing on the
planet couldn't be more so it's not
human based so do you are you when you
say that because you said that on our on
the podcast as well is there partners or
no partners no partners period no
partners period no partners ever ever
meanwhile I've only had partners like
select you know now I've had family
members if you want extreme happiness as
a purebred entrepreneur it's all about a
place mmm and incentivizing the [ __ ] out
of them because you're an artist and as
an artist you want to write your song
the end yeah we need to understand that
entrepreneurs are artists you want Pablo
Picasso didn't want to Co paint well
this is so this is this so much so the
point that I was trying to make earlier
was really that was a good
- very good when Pablo Picasso didn't
want to cocaine I'm married to my wife a
long [ __ ] time we were together 15
years were married almost 13 years and
it's a it's an incredibly awesome
healthy relationship we happen to think
very much alike if we did not think a
lot of like it probably wouldn't work
out you also have your outlets where you
guys get to be the Alpha within your
framework
well she [ __ ] runs the show that's
mr. straight-up truth and I'm cool with
that and she doesn't call you to tell
you how work to run your business she
doesn't tell me to run my business she
would like to see me a little bit more
but that's like that's another different
thing like but the reason you guys are
fulfilled is you get to be a non partner
in your craft mm-hmm and then you come
together be partners in your
relationship but the one thing that I
think is interesting in business because
it's very [ __ ] similar to a marriage
like very very similar in terms of the
amount of time you spend together the
decisions that you have to make together
so in business they tell you to find
somebody who thinks totally [ __ ]
different like I think they don't think
they don't they do and then the book
comes out three years later that says
find somebody who thinks exactly like
you you just hear that part because you
know it's wrong for you
mm-hmm and I'm sure right now somebody's
banging on the steering wheel saying
these two [ __ ] morons I have had a
37-year successful partnership with
Barry and these two [ __ ] idiots don't
know what the [ __ ] they're talking about
you're right this is all self-awareness
it's all contextual and it comes down to
that you and this all starts with being
self-aware you know many people are
awesome partners because they love being
a 1b and they want the 1a AJ was a great
partner to me he knew I wanted the
limelight I wanted to say there's a lot
of different versions yeah I'm a great
partner too I didn't give a [ __ ] about
the money nor do I still as much as
having to say in the limelight I'm doing
it for the craft I'm doing it for the
Hall of Fame I'm not doing it for the
money which is why I don't have anywhere
close to as much money as I've actually
earned do you think that doing it for
the money
that is there any long-term [ __ ] is
there a light is there is there a shelf
life for doing it for the money though
yeah I hate that game bro is there a
shelf life honestly I
no everybody's different my it's
unbelievable how vulnerable I think
athletes do you think do it for the
money
a lot because athletes are a little bit
interesting to me a lot of athletes it's
their number one out financially in
comparison to alternatives do you know
many people don't realize how many
athletes hate being an athlete you were
to you so you said that the other day I
did so what what what is that what is
that like what is that conversation like
like interesting um this is why I love
Boehner Sports we're you know we're I'm
thoughtful I love this [ __ ] right I like
being a psycho so like it's really fun
like they know that this was the way to
make 11 million dollars and they're also
smart a lot of the athletes like hearing
what I'm saying right now cuz they're
like right Gary's right at 34 I'll be
done with this I'll have 13 in the bank
and then I can go be an artist and
future so it's kind of cool like I think
the modern-day athlete is far more
thoughtful than a lot of people think I
will tell you one of the most misbranded
things in our current pop culture
Society is athletes they are
dramatically better guys and gals than
people give them credit for
they're dramatically more thoughtful but
people want to go into the drugs beating
the girl like the headlines [ __ ] life
right like that's like ready ready
that's the reverse of how we look at
Wall Street today Wall Street will do
far more worst human things than
athletes that is not the perception in
mainstream American culture you don't
think so no way okay no even to
Entertainment I'm talking real [ __ ] I'm
talking beating mm-hmm women I'm talking
rape I'm talking no I do not believe
that I believe they think that their
bros and bad [ __ ] guys are just care
about money and they have hookers and
coke but but truly like going to jail
like like like Darian Hernandez yeah
that's right mhm no I don't know I don't
believe that's a perception yeah I think
athletes are grossly it's unblock
routing these get and working these kids
when they're 20 think about enough much
of a knucklehead you were right and it
just blew I'm telling you 99 out of 100
these kids are great [ __ ] kids I mean
I I like I would love nothing more than
to sit down with say qualm Barclay and
[ __ ] well he's obvious
no no he's obviously awesome
it's an amazing kid I'm actually talking
like that scale mm-hmm it's like the
masses because that's how I look at it
now like I know I have a good read on
300 urge me the judgment on athletes
after a [ __ ] postgame interact or
listen what about appearance I mean
let's call it what it is just you know
overlaying America's racial issues
overlaying the fact that these kids are
swaggy and they're always gonna be
trendy with their clothes which
inherently seems not conservative which
is fear-based like you know slang all of
it what did you think about the Giants
passionate passing on Haskins I thought
I parties you think they were gonna they
were gonna pick shot this is for I have
to be very transparent now we recruited
very heavily daniel Jones before he was
a major prospect mmm-hmm yeah see that
on Twitter daniel Jones sat in
vaynermedia's office we were on it
before he was a major prospect we were
on it big shout-out to Brian McLaughlin
on our team on it
we spoke to me we we were like this is
the guy so I actually think he's a
better quarterback than Dwayne and I
think Dwayne's a nice athlete and like
but I just think Dana's gonna be a
better out of self quarterback so when
he gets picked giant fans freak out I
get text I reply to all of them we
missed out on this kid by a hair I
wanted him super bad like we literally
did you think that did you were you like
that you're gonna pick I Daniel Jones
should have what number one in this NFL
track that's what did you think about
Giants picking Barkley overed Arnold to
hear that was a mistake you did and I
still do really yes I do I could be
wrong and I think I mean right now
running backs don't win Super Bowls but
quarterbacks do listen are you okay
Arnold stoked
a couple things on this one Barclay is a
big-time running back not just a running
back that's the best ever number two
right now darn 'old between mono and the
way the Jets are playing everybody's
listings like this guy's homering it
they don't realize that I've not liked a
single Jets quarterback besides one I
was super wrong about Kellen Clemens
years ago so where I'm at there's no you
know there's no way I'm doing anything
with that I won't even touch that okay
you're wearing it good so this is my
only room there's some running but
we'll say this I'm excited to clip this
in 12 years and post it on whatever the
Instagram of the day is because I think
look he could get injured cuz that
sports
I really think Donald is a top-tier
quarterback right now we have an
atrocious offensive line situation by
the way the same reason I think Daniel
Jones is a top-tier record like it's
crazy to me this is a real fun story
Vayner sports had a final meeting I was
in Sam Doc this is actually two story I
haven't said this very often but I want
to give you some scoops because I might
podcast the blow up I was in Sam
Donald's living room with his parents
pitching Vayner sports we got to the
final meeting was super cool they were a
small company but using my leverage we
got in the mix I said Sam if I had the
ability to make the future happen and I
had the choice of you signing with
Boehner Sports and going number one
overall to the Browns and letting the
nice of this and let's be very clear
here you signing with Vayner sports
right now for our business which
transcend our business it would put us
on the map in a way that nothing else
could or you don't sign with us you go
with CAA which is where I thought he was
gonna go and where he did go and you go
third to the Jets I would have the
second thing happen of course he did and
that's and that's who actually grabbed
that's who I think he is that's how much
I care about the Jets and and that's
what's happened and I'm pumped because I
like adversity so I like that everyone's
taking a [ __ ] on us
ghosts mono we suck the kid up here is a
[ __ ] beast he's a quiet kid he's not
Baker right he's not gonna be that guy I
couldn't believe more in his psyche and
his actual physical ability now it's
about building an offensive line getting
some wins what do you I mean what do you
get what do you think four years exactly
listen I actually think both of them in
a weird way and I hate to say this cuz I
hate giving giant fans credit but like
Eli had a big time career oh yeah and I
actually think it's super weird that
both Sam and Daniel remind me a lot of
you like like just cerebral like just
like when Jones when Jones played his
first starting game tamp was a Tampa
yeah number eight jersey blue Giants
Jersey was the number one selling jersey
on and
it was I I that that day for me watching
him start that game and win that game
yeah was probably one of the best days I
can recall she's like you sir of course
cuz you start going into oh my god
there's hope we have 13 years of this
there's hope yeah of course
ELISA and he's a pedigree bro he is I
listen I don't know as to tell you we
recruited him before his last year in
college we completely believed we
completely believed we thought he was
the best quarterback in that draft I
still believe that to be true and I was
pissed that the Giants took him Gary
thank you you're the man thank you
brother thank you so much so much I
gotta go I'm super late I'm out of here
[Music]